the wolf from summer school offers
students a lot that they really couldn't
get anywhere else I think is a
completely different experience and
something I've never experienced before
being able to interact with all these
different people with all these kind of
diverse interests in science and
technology and education you know
everything from A to Z has been a really
great experience I think that's very
very useful when you work on a project
and actually have exposure from all
kinds of people they get to interact
first of all with Stephen Wolfram
personally they get to see upcoming more
from technologies and they tend to meet
students from other parts of the world
that they wouldn't really have
opportunities to meet any other way
the teaching style is very different
here you know the lectures are very
hands-on and you know the mentors are
always there around you it's allowed to
do a lot of computation a lot of
experiments I think this makes it more
interactive than classic lecture one one
thing I liked about is are these live
demonstrations it's a nicer learning
experience for for everyone they're
taking their interests in all these
different topics and taking the power of
computation applying to those that's not
something that you would encounter on a
regular University class there's have
been the best experiences on my summer
school and I'm super excited to finish
it off strong
you
[Music]